la surprise qu'est ce qu'ils ont à
cacher on se demande dans cette
commission denquête pourquoi d'un seul
coup elle prend autant d'importance
et qu'est ce que la république en marche
à cacher parce qu'en réalité il ya un
fait hier j'entendais monsieur castetner
qui est le patron de la république en
marche qui disaient qu'ils aient eu un
comportement de voyou
alors pourquoi on essaye de protéger des
gens qui ont un comportement de voyou
auparavant christophe castaner la
semaine dernière a demandé aux sénateurs
de ne pas s'arroger un pouvoir de
destitution du président de la
république à travers cette commission
denquête a coûté sa pas été question ça
jamais été à l'ordre du jour et y'a que
monsieur castaner qui pensent cela
c'était pas du tout à ma connaissance le
but de la commission denquête que pensez
vous de cela estime alain richard c'est
à dire que lui ai dit bien ce n'est pas
utile cette audition puis va être très
difficile de poser des questions sans
interférer sur l' enquête pour lui eh
bien on compte s'imposer c'est pas la
première fois
c'est arrivé souvent qu'une commission
denquête interroge des personnes mis en
examen ainsi monsieur richard veut que
je rappelle que monsieur cahuzac est
passé devant une commission denquête
dont le rapporteur était socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale
pourquoi il n'a pas dit à l'époque par
exemple monsieur qu'elle jacques avait
été mise en examen et il est passé quand
même devant une commission d enquête
parlementaire dois ma connaissance donc
vous jugez que cette commission denquête
sites naturels ne va pas trop loin et
qu'elle ait une enquête
il ya une commission d' enquête sur les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques il y avait
des personnes mises en examen
on a auditionné quand même les personnes
mises en examen c'est le rôle d'une
commission denquête ce qu'il ya
d'étrange dans cette affaire c'est que
normalement la commission denquête
aurait dû se dérouler normalement et
peut-être même que ces travaux seraient
déjà achevés et qu'on voit une
crispation du pouvoir de l'exécutif
d'une manière anormale
comme s'il y avait quelque chose à
cacher et ça c'est troublant c'est
étonnant que le garde des sceaux
interviennent pour défendre quelqu'un
qui par ailleurs ont dit qu'ils allaient
a fait des actes qui sont a priori
condamnables
elle s'est effectivement nicole
belloubet notamment s'est interrogé sur
une instrumentalisation de cette
commission denquête croxel manque
d'expérience
il faudrait qu'elle garde des sceaux
voit comment se sont passés les autres
commission denquête surprise j'ai
peut-être le sentiment que dans l'esprit
du pouvoir la commission d' enquête doit
être dirigé par des membres de la
majorité présidentielle
c'est vrai que dans le cas de la
commission cahuzac c'était le président
hollande et que le rapporteur était
socialiste alors c'est beaucoup plus
simple on a vu que la dextérité avec
laquelle la commission denquête s'est
déroulée à l'assemblée nationale où elle
a mis fin à ses travaux très rapidement
elle n'a pas voulu additionnés et donc
découvrir quoi que ce soit on a le
sentiment que pour le pouvoir la
commission denquête n'a de validité que
chez elle est dirigée par des membres du
pouvoir pour mettre la poussière sous le
tapis pont c'est pas le rôle ou en tout
cas au sénat traditionnellement depuis
longtemps des commissions enquête mais
là rien d'extraordinaire
alors vous qui avait d'ailleurs été
président de commission denquête au
sénat comment est-ce que ça se passe
lorsqu'il ya une demande de huis clos on
sait que l'avocat d'alexandre benallal
bien fait planer le doute easy peut-être
qui va demander ce huis clos pour cette
audition prévue mercredi
écoutez c'est un réflexe naturel -
lorsqu'il y avait la commission d'
enquête sur la fraude fiscale ça
arrivait presque régulièrement que la
personne auditionnée sur le conseil de
son avocat devant de huis clos
généralement on l'obtient pas on
obtiendrait s'il y avait des mineurs en
cause s'il ya des des affaires
particulières dont le bureau de la
commission d' enquête le bureau dans
lequel les membres de la république en
marche peuvent siéger le décide
bon vous me dites qui siègent pas ah ben
je ne sais pas ce que va donner le
bureau mais en réalité en l'occurrence
ça ne me semble pas raisonnable et
acceptable on voit pas ce qu'il y a ce
qui pourrait justifier le huit clos dans
cette circonstance là